todos los puntos a resaltar de este más
reciente informe
y muchas gracias raúl y encantada de
estar con ustedes de nuevo
lamentablemente las noticias no son
buenas como hemos visto el informe que
ha sacado naciones unidas es un informe
que sacan todas las agencias de naciones
unidas relacionadas con inseguridad
alimentaria y nutricional una vez al año
y este año pues las noticias son las que
esto has dicho que seguimos aún teniendo
828 millones de personas afectados por
hambre en el 2021 y lo que lo que
decimos es que han aumentado 46 millones
del año anterior esperábamos realmente a
nivel mundial después de que acaba el
impacto más grave del cob y que se
redujera en estos niveles de inseguridad
alimentaria severa y hambre pero sin
embargo no lo hemos visto no lo hemos
visto porque continúan las desigualdades
sociales continúan una recuperación muy
lenta la crisis climática y ahora claro
últimamente también la crisis ucrania si
eso precisamente lo quería abordar con
usted porque este informe del año 2021
pero como ha grabado la guerra en
ucrania esta situación que también está
como sabemos represados a toneladas
cereales de trigo en ucrania como agrava
esto la situación alimentaria en el
mundo
si mira como programa mundial de
alimentos a nivel mundial nos ha
afectado enormemente el programa mundial
de alimentos trabaja aproximadamente en
82 países y realmente nuestros esfuerzos
se han duplicado en este momento tanto
porque necesitamos más dinero para
comprar las raciones que se les dan a
las personas en seguridad alimentaria
como también las transferencias
monetarias tienen que aumentar porque
los precios globales han aumentado
enormemente de los productos básicos
sobre todo entonces en este momento
también estamos extremadamente
preocupados en latinoamérica y el caribe
para decirte un ejemplo en latinoamérica
el caribe desde que empezó la crisis de
ucrania hasta hoy en los 13 países donde
el programa mundial de alimentos trabaja
hemos aumentado un millón de personas
más en inseguridad alimentaria severa y
vamos bien a fin de año acabamos con 8.7
millones de personas en inseguridad
alimentaria severa en nuestra región y
ahora hemos aumentado un millón más en
pocos meses estamos realmente
extremadamente preocupados y hay que
tomar acciones muy rápidas para evitar
un deterioro como el que llegamos
durante el pico del cobi 17 puntos 7
millones de personas en nuestros países
donde trabaja el programa 'un de
alimentos que son 3 en nuestra región
lola esas acciones necesarias para poder
mejorar en lo que cabe esta situación
cómo se puede lograr y cómo ha sido la
cooperación digamos con los gobiernos de
nuestra región
mira los gobiernos de la región en
latinoamérica del caribe tuvieron unas
acciones espectaculares durante el kobe
19 aumentaron los las transferencias
sociales tanto en comida como en
monetarias realmente se
preocuparon de que las personas más
vulnerables más pobres tuvieran una
transferencia social el problema que
tenemos ahora es que nos encontramos con
un espacio fiscal limitadísimo se han
acabado las reservas en muchos países
hay alto endeudamiento y ese alto
endeudamiento junto junto con una
inflación de precios de los alimentos
enorme un costo del transporte de los
alimentos enorme y luego también el
déficit de algunos alimentos que como
sabemos y tú bien mencionaste hay muchos
que se producen en la cuenca del mar
negro y están creando tanto una subida
de precios a nivel mundial como un
déficit de ellos a nivel mundial
entonces teniendo todo eso en
consideración realmente tenemos que
volver a esto
a ver quiénes son las personas de mayor
inseguridad alimentaria como nos dice
este informe que salió del 2021 pero
ahora en el 2022 tenemos que identificar
los tenemos que realmente hacer acciones
inmediatas para evitar que se aumente la
pobreza que se aumente la inseguridad
alimentaria y también sobre todo mujeres
y niños que son los que sufren más de
anemia de desnutrición y son los más
afectados inmediatamente y los que
realmente vamos a tener que atender
inmediatamente en toda nuestra región en
todo el mundo